okay andrew
you got a question about why young men
today
are that much different from past
generations can you just explain
yeah so excuse me um i've noticed like
i'm 22 myself
i noticed that my parents generation and
then i noticed
um the ones after them like my uncles in
his 40s probably around your age
and then my generation i've noticed that
the older guys seem to have
a better mind frame uh better just
better
view on life but then you look at the
guys today uh
like my age and they're all very weak
and pussified
yeah and i'm wondering what what your
take is on why this may have happened
besides the points you list do you think
that there's other factors
that everything dude it's it's like
everything like
i could i mean i could probably carry
a camera around for 24 hours and i could
film everything that i
that i would come across that pussifies
the western mail
everything from advertisement to media
to government
to this [ __ ] like vaccine [ __ ] with
the masks and all that like
99 point something like nine eight
percent of people that get
the beer bug survive no problem but
let's lock down everything for two years
and make everybody wear my like
the pussification is real and it's been
going on for a long long time and they
just keep
adding more [ __ ] to the tool kit
that they can use on society to make it
more compliant and weak i was talking to
um
the guy that does the uh krav maga
instruction at my dojo
the other day and he was talking ab
because
dude's like 57 and there's no way that i
could take him down
at all at all like if i were to try to
choke him out he would just go like this
and break it because he's got no neck
right like yeah this guy's a [ __ ]
weapon
and he sees it himself he's like they
want you weak
you can only control weak people you
can't control
strong people you can only control the
weak i've noticed
that with myself like so they keep
feeding you
all this information that keeps you weak
and compliant and sucking on
you know the uh government teat you know
they've got all these social programs
which keeps people poor and they keep
voting for more of this stuff which
keeps them poor with more free money and
the taxes more of the rich so
like the entire way that society is
built right now it doesn't encourage
rich people to chase excellence because
of taxation it doesn't encourage
poor people to get up off their asses
and make something out of themselves if
they get
you have to keep getting free money
right and do you think that this would
ever
improve like i know myself i see very
you can improve yourself forget about
the world
yeah dude one of the most popular
questions i get from guys is like how do
you change this like how do you make
this better i got an email from a guy
earlier today with this with this long
essay i think i might do a video on it
and read it but it's
basically signed at the end regards a
man that misses women
right oh god and he's not a mgtow he's
not an mra but he's got this big
solution on
how to solve all the problems in the
world blah blah blah and it's like
stop worrying about the world around you
and worry about yourself
you're right no you're right track track
your own testosterone levels every year
i bet most of you guys out there right
now have no idea what your
testosterone numbers are you have no
idea what your estrogen levels are you
have no idea if your vitamin d
is sufficient or not you have no idea
about any of those things i bet
right those are the things that you can
control and track yourself you know and
you can improve those if you're an older
guy you can get on trt if you're a
younger guy pick up heavy [ __ ] put it
down develop a masculine you know
physique
your balls work perfectly in your 20s
get all the free tea that you want from
that
yeah right it's like you know forget
about everybody else
and work on improving yourself so that
you're in a position where
you basically have fu money yeah no i
see what you mean yeah and you don't
care about them like
yeah let it burn like you just sit back
you're like [ __ ] it let it burn
while you're on your silent yacht in the
caribbean
getting all your freezer away from the
sun cruising around
okay you got ladies on the boat you got
one important lady
bunch of them i don't know whatever the
hell it is you want to do yeah you just
go and do
you and let the whole [ __ ] thing burn
stop worrying about everything else out
there and focus on yourself and do you
i'm not gonna lie i think i think as a
younger guy i think it's a little bit
harder and that's no excuse obviously
but i think it's a little bit harder to
navigate no i get it man because you've
been told all your life you know
you have to go fix things we have to
like they've been telling men for ages
you do what's right what do they tell
the girls
right for you yeah you do what's right
for you yeah right that's true
so stop worrying about fulfilling all of
their prophecies and
being a little pawn in the chessboard
board for them don't break the law
you know if you don't like you know
where you live move
but you know put yourself first you know
build something
out of yourself obviously right yeah i
think i need to read your book a second
time then yeah maybe to re-clarify
things
read it again man yeah um also if you
haven't read jack donovan stuff
read his books as well because he talks
about tribalism masculinity
um he doesn't specifically use the terms
mental point of origin but
a lot of what he talks about is this
empire of nothing
like right we have this big [ __ ]
world with infrastructure and highways
and airports and electric cars and gas
cars and diesel cars and
you know all this [ __ ] [ __ ] out there
that we're supposed to be all proud of
but realistically it's an empire of
nothing it's true
um before if i look up his books like is
it just a
whole slew of books or is there one
specific that you'd recommend um
if you go to the top pinned comment on
any of my main videos so not on the
shorts
there's amazon recommended reading list
just click that
and you'll see all the books that i
recommend there and whichever ones i'd
suggest reading
they're in there for jack donovan's
repertoire okay perfect i appreciate
your insight
it helps a lot you got it bro see you
thanks a lot
you